simone biles reveals her first boyfriend
and here's what we know about the
Olympic champs new man
[Music]
Simone May thinks Instagram official
Monday night posting this pic of the
pair gazing into each other's eyes she
captioned it always smiling with you so
who is the lucky guy meet Stacy Ervin a
23 year old psychology major attending
the University of Michigan he works as
head coach for the world champion Center
and get this he's a fellow gymnast
although stacy is the dancing with the
star alums first official relationship
back in April Simone dished on her
lackluster dating history at rehearsals
with her partner Sasha Farber they've
been on like one Navy property now but
Simone couldn't stop gushing over her
then mystery man he's got a good body
I'm just saying it's I'm just saying
well that explains why Simone praised
his fit physique so far we can't get
enough of this cute couple they attended
a Bryson tiller concert together
Stacy escorted Simone to her US
gymnastics Hall of Fame induction
ceremony over the weekend and the two
looks like a match made in heaven he
wrote in the caption quote words cannot
express how incredibly proud I am of you
you make me feel like I am the luckiest
man alive I'm ready for myself
[Music]